(crowd stirring)
- [Man] Go, go, go, go, go, go!
- [Narrator] Esports isn't just a fad;
it's a massive cultural phenomenon
set to take over the world with
a new generation of athletes
battling in virtual worlds created
using advanced computing technology.
- And it takes a
supercomputer to really make
this lifelike game environment exist.
Textures, the hair, the effect
of wind, how water moves,
all of these things are
being physically modeled
at a speed that feels very real,
and they're doing that with technology
and they're doing that in cooperation
with us at Hewlett Packard Enterprise.
(keyboard keys clacking)
My earliest programming experiences
were literally solving
tic-tac-toe-style games
on personal computers back in the '80s.
(keyboard keys clacking)
Now I'm building some of the world's
most powerful supercomputers
to take on some of the world's
most grand scientific problems
in a computational way.
Supercomputers are used in all
kinds of applications today,
based on this very simple idea
of modeling and simulation.
When we don't understand
something physically,
it helps us to build a model of it,
and we do that in software now.
First, we develop the
physical characteristics
of the object, and then
we act on it with forces
to simulate real-world phenomena.
You can think of pushing on the object,
and does it compress, does
it crush, how does it move,
how fast, how does it interact
with its surroundings.
We use them to forecast the weather.
We use them to predict where
the stock market is going.
We use them to design cars and airplanes.
I don't think folks understand
that behind all that is supercomputing.
(electronic synthesizer music)
Gaming technology relies
heavily on graphical processing,
or GPUs, instead of CPUs.
GPUs use a divide-and-conquer
approach to data.
We use those same GPUs
now in supercomputing
to solve mathematical equations.
Fundamentally, what
this will allow us to do
is build larger, more
powerful supercomputers.
An individual chip today, can perform
a trillion mathematical
equations per second.
A trillion!
There's no end to the
capabilities of the human race
to make advances through
mathematical simulations.
That's what excites me, to be
able to see the advancements
that that 12-year-old kid
couldn't have imagined.
Today, anything's possible.
(electronic synthesizer music)